[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay
there we go kyle shadow what's up hello
hello it's good to be here atlas
thank you for inviting me i really like
the setup and everything looks great
so damn pumped for this conversation
what a dope
highlight reel we watched of your work
appreciate you
i'm so so pumped to unpack the
creativity of that the artistry of that
and just the art of video and
communication dissemination in general
we have
we have that one to unpack we have the
other music videos that you've done to
unpack we have the highlighting of other
creators and artists promotional videos
sort of
videos you know personality you know
capturing people's personality on camera
is definitely
yes a fact that's this i love to do it
yes
it's fun it's exactly what we do here we
capture the
expression of someone's consciousness in
a conversation and you do it
in a very similar way but then you
repackage it into
something that takes a long time to
layer put the right audio put the right
video
put the right transitions animations all
this different
there's a lot of aspects to look at when
you're making something
anything really from uh from uh you know
you can use your cell phone
even it's still not it's complicated but
it's definitely uh
it's an acquired skill i think yeah and
we have actually also a
cool breakdown of
kyle's premiere project that we're going
to show
as well which will be good and that'll
hopefully give some insight into the
creative process for those that
are getting deeper into it themselves
let's jump in from the journey
perspective walk us through
who you were growing up yeah how you
actually got
interested in what you care about today
okay uh i was born in alameda california
the bay area we're both bay area people
that's right
um yeah and uh i love it down there is
great but it doesn't snow
so um when i was in
fourth grade i think uh i i moved to a
place called grass valley california
which is of northmoor it does snow there
and everybody all my friends were like
well send us the snow
like just make snowballs and send it in
the mail to us i'm like that's not gonna
work you know it snow's gonna melt
so i did the next best thing i got a
little handheld camcorder
and started filming the snow and uh and
i think my first narrative
was me building a snowman so like i'd
take different cuts and kind of splice
it together and uh
sony it's before sony vegas but it was a
old old editing software so i just like
chop it together
and then that's basically when i knew i
just wanted to do it you know
so that was kind of the the beginning
then from then i went to school
i actually got work in 2008 in grass
valley
um as a videographer wedding dj
so that was a lot to on the table you
know hauling hauling all that equipment
and stuff and
just trying to make it work i would not
recommend anybody
do that ever it's a terrible but uh
you know i wanted to stay with the video
videography aspect of it
so i went to school in the bay and then
um finished that
and now i'm in la of course because
everybody goes to la but now everybody's
moving out of la
so we'll see what happens not everybody
not everybody yeah a lot of people are
like
yeah like three weeks ago we came
through and a lot of other people are
still coming through
in your journey i thought it was
interesting that you were describing how
there was this friendship
from people that don't experience snow
that then
we're like you know get us that taste of
how that feels to have that snow
and then you put it together in a video
and that was kind of one of the early
takes and then i also appreciated how
you're saying like
there's a big complicated process with
videographers becoming their own
sovereign independent creators
as we're going to talk about and what
happens is that
sometimes you get
you get brought into industries like the
wedding industry
and stuff like that to make that's where
everybody starts man like you can't
start where you want to start
it's all about the journey you know like
you gotta you gotta go from
point a to point b and there's no
there's no way to jump that
you know i tried believe me yeah yeah
it's impossible yeah me too
yeah when i first came to the bay area i
was very much like
i was 19 and i was like you know where
are the
entrepreneurs that are going to just
take me under their wing and help me
execute all my ideas right and it was
like no shortcuts
it's literally grinding like five years
to figure out
the north star and how to execute it
exactly exactly and
the same thing in that journey for you
you got to start like in that wedding
industry and kind of like
and what's interesting is that you pick
up a lot of really good experience
in that process i learned so much you
know and the common uh
the common agreement is that like film
school it's good for some things
but honestly the best way to learn is to
do it right so yeah
meeting people networking is definitely
an important aspect of that um
getting on board like going to shoots
and just seeing how things work
i think is is one of the most important
things yes the actual experiential
learning that occurs when
it's life
in general is the best school and so
like to actually
put yourself in the positions like
you're saying where if you are an
aspiring videographer
you really have to put yourself on the
sets you have to put yourself behind the
camera you have to put yourself behind
the editing software you have to put
yourself
in that struggling process where you're
like where's the best free audio
libraries and like how do i maybe
collaborate with someone that actually
makes
music themselves or maybe i should pick
up some music skills myself
and like how do i find the best
transitions animations how do i make
those
like you got to put yourself you know
once
when like literally when you've never
made a video for a client before you
have to like write
on your website like i make videos for
clients exactly yeah you kind of have to
lie at the beginning
i mean that's the thing but it's uh it's
true though
you kind of have to put yourself out
there you definitely have to put
yourself out there
and uh honestly the wedding the wedding
jobs was
i had ups and downs but i learned more
than i think i did at film school um
film school is great for networking and
meeting people but
honestly weddings uh [ __ ] me up in
such a way
that i'm okay i'm okay with it now like
you bring me on set where everything's
going wrong and everything's [ __ ] up
and i'm fine
you know i roll through it you know yeah
it's definitely something that
is necessary to learn it's interesting
that you say that
your learning
came a lot from outside of film school
which is super interesting to think
about
big time yeah and i i generally
agree that i think for the vast majority
of people's north star pursuits
that they must focus
vast majority of their time and energy
on learning outside of the
sort of centralized collegiate system
and that the centralized collegiate
system works for a specific
sub set of fields that
work even in
fields like medicine it's
cool that there's the systematized
process for people to
become doctors but at the same time
how often does western medicine have
absolutely nothing to do with
nutrition or eastern medicine or
meditation or spirituality right
right yeah yeah it's kind of one one
path you can take and uh
i think with the medical field it's a
it's it's a
i think it is important for for most
doctors to go through school and
the rigorous training of that stuff and
i would say the same for film school
except
now you can learn everything on youtube
you know there you go it's all about
it's like
when does film school send you in
experientially is the other thing
because like
with entrepreneurship school right
business schools
you know you spend all that time on all
those
classes on entrepreneurship but when do
you actually go and do the
apprenticeships
when you're actually there it's the
numbers it's like the political numbers
side of things rather than
actually going out and doing it and
that's the same thing i would say with
video is that
if i if i throw you into the actual
forcing function
of the environment and i give you a
deadline and i say that in two weeks
you have to have captured content and
put music on transitions
and and cut it really well layered it
down that
um and you have a due date in two weeks
and that we're going to have the whole
quote class or if your one-on-one mentor
is reviewing that with you and giving
you that feedback
if if i make you do one of those videos
every two weeks if i
force you to make a youtube channel and
that you have to
in one year you have to make one video
every two weeks
by the end of that year you're gonna
have a youtube channel with 25 videos
on it 26. it's going to be awesome yeah
and that you're going to have this like
catalog i would say that
correct me if i'm wrong would you say
that what we just talked about there
is that the best forcing function to get
people
to become better at videography
is say make a video every two weeks
publish it on youtube absolutely for a
year yeah absolutely i would say that's
that's
the best way to do it and i would tell
anybody that you know i know people that
have uh full-time jobs that are that are
starting to
get interested in sort of starting their
own freelance like making music videos
and this kind of thing
um and that's the first thing i would
say like if you never picked up a camera
before it doesn't matter
how good the camera is you know you you
pick it up and you go shoot things
right like that's that's the only way to
do it and do it with other people too
because
because that's that's a huge thing too
yeah
and then do cool things i like this a
lot you you kind of started
introducing it which is that on this
forcing function of the year of doing a
video every two weeks
what you can begin doing is you can do
cool things like saying
okay one time the first video i'm gonna
go out maybe by myself and i'm going to
capture
maybe the beach or the redwoods or
whatever nature stuff maybe or whatever
right
or maybe you're the day in the life
videos maybe you just make a day in the
life of your own life
video okay for the first video the
second
video that you make that second two week
period
i like this idea of now recruit three
friends
and then maybe you go with your three
friends to capture the life of your
group
and the uniqueness of your friends in
the group i like that i like that this
might be my uh
2021 to-do list this is the master class
bro yeah
we're literally making the master class
motivational
and then the next one the next the third
one that
could be now why don't we
pick someone that really resonates with
our north star so maybe like our
family member had recently had a
a pathology develop in their body in a
specific field of science
and that now we become more familiar
with that specific field of science and
so
maybe we take something like alzheimer's
and neurodegeneration
because maybe our family member had that
spend your own knowledge and sort of
bring it to other people
and then go so not only in that third
video
it would be to have done a lot of
research on neurodegeneration
alzheimer's
but and then to in incorporate some of
these videos of like
neural networks and incorporate some of
the videos of what
these uh beta-amyloid plaque tangles
actually look like that inhibit the
neural communication no bro i know me
too
me too from from the neuroscientists
that actually study this
and it would be interesting then to also
go on site
to an actual practicing
neuroscientist that works in the field
of neurodegeneration and
interview them yeah and then take 30
seconds or 60 seconds or a couple
minutes of the
great points that they bring up and put
that in the video
so now we're making a really good third
video yeah exactly i love that free form
and then
you know based on how that growth is
just on those three videos
that would be incredible to see where
that goes in the future
and that's how it works right that's how
that's how you got started and yes it's
a
it's basically you just now you have a
following and it's all
your place looks amazing and look at
this setup you know hell yeah
yeah and likewise likewise with you
is that you get this kind of slow and
steady over time
iterative process from doing the
capturing the
the snowman and that process all the way
to
uh up to film school and up to the
iterations working for clients in la
all right beautiful i'm glad we
literally mapped out the beginning of a
master class there i love it okay
fantastic i love it okay
so take us to take us to what happened
with that
trigger you know you're finishing up the
film school you're doing more of these
iterations you've done wedding stuff
you've done
these different things but now you're
starting to kind of
figure out okay well what's kyle's north
star
and like what would it mean if i didn't
have to do
maybe wedding stuff but if i could
transition to doing more work that was
oriented with my ethos and how did the
moment come to also come to l.a walk us
through that process okay so there's
a specific moment that i can remember
that was the turning point for me
um i was doing a job in uh in the bay
and i was moving i was in the process of
moving so i had a bunch of
you know everything was in the back of
my car and you know san francisco can be
kind of a sketchy place
so i made the mistake of you know
parking on the street and with
everything i own my cameras my laptops
everything the hard drives everything
and i come back to my car and it's all
gone yeah they got broken
broken into it everything's stolen
everything my toothbrush my clothes
everything
so that was that was definitely a
turning point i was like okay
um this is either that happened to me
multiple times in san francisco and it
was
cars broken into it was just backpacks
stolen
from underneath of my feet i mean tripod
super interesting
and like the worst time too i was moving
so literally almost everything i owned
was in that car
but then that dematerialized you and
cleansed you
it was completely exactly it was a
humbling experience and i i took i took
a step back and i looked at
what i wanted to do and i thought like
there's no way i can't do anything other
than what i've been doing because you
know i love it so [ __ ] much
and i'm not gonna turn around for that
i'm not gonna get a job at a gas station
although
you know i you know for temporarily you
know i was up in the air but
um i would i'd immediately hit up some
friends that lived in other places and
my friend brandon lived in los
angeles and was like yeah you can crash
on my couch so i just
came out here and uh with like 200
and that's where i am now you know
things have been going well
i love it yeah i love it what a great
hey shout out brandon and the homies
thank you brandon yes that make this
happen where you ping them and
they're like yeah come move into the to
the
to the new chapter of your life and i'll
can be conducive of that with my couch
or whatever
exactly and then also the
that spirit in you which is basically
this you know the leap of faith which
it's a tough thing but you you
you have to trust the fact that you're
following your intuition you're
following your north star you're
following that big vision
and so that way you you go into the
chaos in this case it's a lot of chaos
it's 200
and a brand new city sleeping on a couch
trying to make it
i would recommend it to anybody honestly
i would say if you haven't had
experience like that
do your best to make yourself
uncomfortable and see what happens like
you've got to find your passion you've
got to find your north star um
like as you say yeah i think that's the
most important thing and it's not about
like
where you think it'll bring you to like
i don't know where this is going to take
me yes
it's all about the journey journey
that's right so the ups and downs of
roller coaster
you know you you learn a lot along the
way but i think it's
definitely worth it for everybody to
experience yeah we uh just
on yesterday's show with josh we were
talking about how
on that north star which is basically
one of the most important metaphysical
aspects to reality is that for the
individual to have identified what their
own unique artistic expression is in the
world
and for them to be in pursuit of that
transcendent noble
aim that drives meaning and purpose on a
daily basis for them
what's interesting is that we have
the identification of it generally
and then we're very loose about the
process
and the journey and we're in a
moment-to-moment
place of love and peace
and bliss as much as we can
channeling those highest forms of
consciousness along the way
it's a messy process it's not a clean
one there's nobody else
like if you're doing life this way if
you know i would recommend
um if you if you're if you're living
life like a freelancer right if you're
doing what you love then there's no set
path
like there's people that have done it in
every every which way and every every
one of them has failed
in different points in time so nobody's
doing it the perfect way
you know yeah and uh yeah it's the best
you just learn
as you go i'm glad that you bring up
that very
yes theory slogan of seek discomfort
it's really important i completely agree
go outside of that comfort zone
with those experiences especially when
it comes to pursuit of the north star
and especially when it comes to moving
to places that you think are more
conducive for that north star like the
metro areas or whatnot
totally so let's talk about
when exactly did you
end up in la getting
more involved with photography
and picking up these gigs yep so um
photography is is a fun thing i like to
do
i like to play with light and stuff it's
it's uh it's kind of like a hobby even
though they're basically the same thing
photos or photos are you know it's a
simpler version of video
in my mind but uh yeah when i moved here
i just started doing uh
uh i hit up some uh background acting
places and i you know you get on set and
people are doing it there and you get to
see how things work more in in
los angeles and and a lot of background
acting is just
you know walking around but anyway let
me talk about these pictures
this is a for these are for music videos
and these are sort of just off the top
um we didn't plan these shots out this
is like in between takes
for a music video um
but i just like see this lighting and uh
i just you know spot it whip out the
little camera and take a picture you
know
yeah i love stuff like this thank you
it's almost like every single one of
these captures is
very deeply artistic i love it
thank you thank you and yeah this uh
this is my
friends tyler and catherine shout out
father katherine
um yeah they just capturing the moment
of love
exactly yeah yeah
and it takes a while to become this good
at it takes a lot of iterations
of yeah to become this good
it's it's been how many years of even
just photography and
and setting those up and i started like
at seven years old
exactly yeah i got my first job
professionally in 2008 october 2008
so it's been like 12 years 12 years
exactly yeah
so 12 years to learn really how to put
stuff like
like this together and also do it in
post as well there's a lot of
right yeah right is it uh it's like
lightroom and photoshop my room
i barely use photoshop and it's a
lightroom i mean lightroom has
everything you need in it yeah
it's uh you can remove things you can
kind of edit pictures like that
adobe adobe's the [ __ ] shout out adobe
yeah for sure
they have adobe creative suite is very
important it's so crucial
for artists portraiture i love doing
portraits
um playing with lights head shots are
fun
so then okay so over time i want to just
also indicate over time
you become more and more again it's like
this would be another in a sense we
could make another quick like master
class which is like
literally post one picture a day
onto instagram yeah right there's you
know next master class it's like you
have to forcing function yourself to get
really good
at taking these profound photographs and
then bringing them into lightroom
editing them really nicely
if you do one a day you're you're gonna
get good at it
that's what i would say for followers to
do exactly
yeah yeah because when you look at
like for example um
for example
first like first of all you know you
really need to be more creative
like for some for me like i wouldn't i
wouldn't realize like we can find such a
profound
photo of is this literally in the rain
no this is
inside there's an indoor rain room i
love this wow there are literally
indoor rain rooms this is a los angeles
man you have everything here
that's so interesting yeah fd studios in
downtown l.a has
an indoor rain room you could bring cars
into it great for music videos
great for music yeah you see you
actually see him in a lot of music
videos now watch a music video i'm like
i don't know where that is
i know where that is yeah yeah
oh my gosh indoor rain rooms there you
go and so you
there you go you're like okay we're
gonna express a
an essence like we talk about this on
the show that each of our individual
guests that come on the program are
their own unique
aromas like flowers that they express
right in this case
these images and videos are also their
own unique aromas that they're
expressing
this is super unique where you have
the indoor rain room and you have the
i don't even know how you managed to get
that crazy
like lighting the lighting yeah um yeah
definitely look at it look at batman
look at a lot of those movies that
how they light like now if i watch a
movie it kind of ruins the experience
for other people
because i'm like i'm like looking at the
lighting and like oh that's how they did
that you know like
when they like in batman if you look at
the rain it's all backlit so it's like
backlitting any backlighting anything is
a great idea in my opinion
yeah it just makes everything look so
good which which you do also
in this one which i love a lot you have
the back light specifically behind
the head which makes it look like it's
glowing and the person's going yeah and
he also has a fill light on uh
on the uh coming from the left-hand side
yes that makes him look like he's
glowing yeah so that's actually a
tongue's
more tungsten than than the back light
is so like
i like i mean people say not to do it
but mixed lighting i think it's it can
be cool it can be cool it can be cool
yeah yeah interesting um
wow yeah because when you do that
breakdown when you're like it's more
tungsten on the left and it's mixed
lighting because that one's more
would you say it's white or what do you
call it daylight daylight yeah okay
interesting
so if we can break down the quick light
spectrum when it's
more orange you call that more tungsten
tungsten yeah that would be lower
uh in the kelvin scale so lower 30
kilohertz
is and then you go up to like 5700 57
is most is daylight it's daylight so
meaning that's right
yeah most like uh like these like the
white like these guys yeah these are
okay so studio lights that are like
white like
what you guys are lighting right yeah
especially what you're getting
on like what on these on these side
on the side shots um these are these are
more kelvin higher kelvin and so they're
more
daylight and then the tungsten is like
the
three thousand kelvin or twenty five
hundred dollars exactly
and then but i am dyslexic so there's
there's other i'm a little dyslexic
yeah i'm mixing stuff up but i'm pretty
sure that's right you know yeah i'm not
super technical but this is that
spectrum okay
yeah yeah i i like i like that a lot
because then
it enables so many more artistic
essences to be expressed because some of
them are
there's that massive light spectrum for
you to be able to pick and choose from
as well yeah exactly
and it keeps going down to um you know
like
like [ __ ] forgot what it's called
like uh
and never mind i forget i forgot the the
mercury sort of style like yeah yeah
i'm actually really interested in it now
and that's another thing that the
spectrum that we see is so small
even to what other mammals see you know
like other animals like
birds hawks
infrared yeah imagine seeing an infrared
like
you can obviously they got flare cameras
but i wonder
um yeah so here's
here's a little bit of data on it here
let's let's try and let's try and pull
this up for people
all right we're gonna show you six now
okay and then here you go guys okay so
if you just look up
you know like photography and kelvin i
mean
there's this one here
these kind of candles yeah that was
right interesting so
candle 3500 house light bulbs are
usually tungsten that gives you that
warmer
flavor um i see in daylight's 5500
yeah it starts at 55 50. i don't know if
i've ever seen dark
shade whatever that it might be like a
black light
yeah so that'd be around 70. and there's
this one as well
yeah another one another version of that
to show people
yeah so color temperature this is the
the word people use this color exactly
color temperature okay
in kelvin it's measured in kelvin
and so by tweaking this
especially in photography and
videography you basically
can you control everything everything
with lighting
everything inside it's one of those
things that you would love that you
don't really notice
you know if you're watching something
like for example um
the haunting of hill house it does this
in like insanely well
where they'll uh they'll like different
things i think episode six
of the first season they had uh one shot
like a long shot
and they had different areas where the
actors would walk into the whole episode
was basically one shot
and they built a set to where things
would change and like
you know from from the house and then
they would be in the uh
in the morgue of the morgue they were
doing like a funeral and then
they would walk in one shot to the set
of the house and that just blew my mind
there's
like lightning coming through the
windows and there's so many tiny tiny
details
like things you wouldn't notice for
example like they move a statue like
ah and then like you see the behind the
scenes and it's hilarious they're like
the camera's following this person into
a room and then outside of the room
there's like
a hundred crewmates like moving
everything around like during the shot
so that when they come out of that room
everything's different
yep you know it's wild i love that stuff
exactly and all that behind the scenes
is
in essence what drives people to
become more literate because you were
talking about this a moment ago you said
that
now you every time you even watch like
the batman movie or like these really
high level productions
you now see all of the nuances of how
they actually
produce it and make it happen yeah same
thing with me now with
you know music and video and even in the
sciences
because now i'm literally looking at the
layering which we're going to
showcase in this case with with your
videos
and the layering in audios and tracks
the layering and
in terms of like the
in like biology would be something like
the cell and then you have the organ and
then you have the organism and then you
have the civilization
you know that kind of a thing and so
there's all these layers
and like if you begin seeing in those
layers in that
systems thinking that's one of as we
talked about with neil sperling on the
show it's one of the ways to become more
of a genius is to see those
totally yeah totally you got to see
those things happen and
sort of what you see on like like it
applies to anything like what you see on
screen
isn't necessarily the uh
what you should be seeing you know what
i mean like think about
how things happen behind the scenes yeah
and you do learn a lot that way
you know i mean i wonder
it would probably be an interesting idea
to
share now
a idea of what happens
because we gave the photography examples
we're going to do the video examples
next
i want to before we do that i want to
share with people what
occurs with the balance
that has to happen between
the
right the client wants the
to collaborate with the photographer
videographer or music producer
etc and that the client wants
their north star to be fulfilled
but they also want to balance
that with the artistic capabilities
and creative direction of what the
artist
can provide in that process it's a
middle ground yeah yeah there's
definitely
definitely middle ground there because
people are getting their minds what they
want and then
those are those are you know a lot of
time you've heard of bridezilla
a lot of time there's like a set zilla
where somebody wants it that's
interesting
wait a second okay so there's an actual
and it's just so
funny because it's literally can you
show them on your shirt too
he's got literally godzilla godzilla on
his
shirt right there that's so funny so
literally there's okay
bridezilla is the word that's used for
kind of like a very
overly controlling yes bride that
wants creative control over the whole
over everything with tiger moms and
their tiger moms and kids okay so we're
drawing an analogy also to setzilla
yeah which is i just made that up oh
that's a new that's a new thing i love
it start using that
everybody you heard it here first set
zilla said jill is uh
it's mostly with independent stuff where
if you're a freelancer you have a client
that wants everything done the exact way
that they imagine in their heads you
know
that's not always the way it's going to
be and a lot of these people don't
understand that
right so i don't want to make any
examples but i've had it i've had a ton
of these
i've had a ton of these people um but i
mean that's the importance of finding
people that you can work with
and actually uh you know making
friends i want to say but you know
having a good relationship with the
people that
you can consistently call upon to to
rely on
you know yeah i think that's really
important you got to work like a
well-oiled machine
like i say yeah like for example you had
a guest on here zebulon
i work with him yeah he's he's a homie
um
he helps me out so much and and the way
we do things
right now is uh it's a godsend man he
salted the earth he kind of
he he will sit in a room with me as i'm
editing and write a song
like a track that i can use right when i
finish it
it's ready to go and like i said it's
all layered out and like during certain
parts it's like
it's perfect you know exactly just drop
it on there
and that that has a lot to do with the
fact that you're both
in the creative project at the same
time so that he's kind of able to see
what he needs to do on a
music production layering to match what
the video
production that you're doing layering is
yeah sometimes down to like the second
exact down to the second yeah and i love
how you
bring up that it's important to as you
go through your creative journey to do
things like
identify when there is some sort of like
a setzilla
style essence and sort of in a sense
distance yourself so that you can
identify the people that are really
great to work with and keep
going in that direction more and more
right so that's one of the things that i
thought was talking about then another
thing is that
we kind of talked about this a bit on
the mastermind side but that in general
it's super important to just capture you
know capture with your iphone to start
right just
yeah and like whether it's photo and
then taking that into lightroom and
posting it on instagram daily or doing
the
on the video uh for your every two weeks
capture right there
on the iphone and then just bring that
import that into premiere and yeah start
doing start simple
um i would say a lot of people
especially around los angeles
uh they they can get the best equipment
and they
they use the best you know cameras and
everything i've been using the same
camera since basically the start of my
career i have
i've had one lens you know and so
it's it's carried me the whole way
because i know how to use it i'm so
you know i i know what to look for
and how to use it right but if you
have like say a 50 000 camera and you
look good that can also help
in this in this city like if you look
legit it can get you to the next stage
but then how you're going to prove it
yeah you know what i mean like you got
to know what you're doing yeah
rule number one so then to know how to
know what you're doing you have to get
out there and do it
right so i would recommend if anybody is
starting out in film
just take the first step and use your
phone through
short film or like animation i did a lot
of claymation when i was a kid
and uh it's definitely a learning
process you can learn about frame rates
and and all that stuff you can learn
about a ton
so yeah yeah take pictures and then
there's also the
idea of like i like how you say that
you can level yourself up by becoming
better and better at the in a sense the
mimetics the better you become
at doing the art in the video or the
music
or the photo space and you showcase that
to the world the more that the world
says that this person
is higher up top notch and so i i want
to keep collaborating
working with them and then there's also
this strange
it kind of relates a little bit to the
setzilla in a way
it's kind of like the like if you show
up to the studio
and you show up with that like that red
camera
and the the you know tens of thousands
of dollars of equipment yeah and then
they look at that and they they're like
this the main person
it's legit and then or like the wedding
photographer that comes with three
cameras on their belt and stuff and
but versus someone that you know you
like
imagine if someone that goes that same
wedding captures photos with their
iphone brings them into lightroom
and then gives you content that's even
better than the wedding photography
which you can do now
the iphone 12 is ridiculous yeah there's
there's a
there's all these you know all these
contests and stuff and a lot of times
people win photo contests now with just
their
iphone which is it's great super
interesting it's yeah everybody in your
pocket you have this thing
that you can do anything with including
become a professional photographer
you know super cool it's wild um
um yeah but uh and you've had one lens
to on your yeah camera yeah that you've
become a master with
yeah yeah just like that yeah um i do
rent occasionally
but that's if i need to exactly yeah
yeah um
wow yeah so you gotta
like it brings you back to seeking
discomfort i wasn't you know i wasn't
at the i wasn't i didn't start off uh
knowing what i was doing with the camera
you know it's part of that whole film
school thing exactly
and uh my film school in particular uh
it was very hands-on it was a two-year
accelerated program you get a four-year
bachelor's degree in two years
so it's pretty much a constant workflow
pull on all nighters with with your
friends and this and that and you really
get to know each other
um most of the class dropped out but we
ended up with like eight people
that to this day i don't think i've seen
a better workflow together even if
[ __ ] hits a fan you know and things are
going wrong
but everybody knows how to handle and we
kind of
you know sneak in there and solve
problems
yeah you know what i mean yeah yeah i
think that's important too
within this
trajectory you end up finding
time over and over and over again that
there's clients
that you can serve that align with your
ethic
that are exciting whether it's in music
production
or whether it's the music videos or
whether it's
showcasing just people that are uh
like we have we have a couple examples
it's probably a good time we'll show
those
we'll show the breakdown as well so
let's um
okay let's start and then you can share
with us
we have ganesh which is gonna be the
first one
this is a music video yeah this is a
halloween release
music video okay that was the very last
minute halloween release
video and so we're gonna play about a
minute from each of these ganesh and
then
we have uh evan bliss we have our mutual
yeah he was also on
this podcast also on the podcast that's
right
and then so this was showcasing kind of
evan as a
building designer yeah so this would be
a promotional video for evan
and uh yeah okay so promotional video
for an individual so
music video promotional video and an
individual and then we have stereo jane
which is a band yeah um they're they're
a band
they're very talented the live
the live shoot you're gonna see uh soon
here
is a single camera shoot but i wanted to
make it look like a multi-camera shoot
so there's there's a learning i mean you
know there's always a learning curve
yeah i'm trying to say yes yes i love
hacks like that are really interesting
yeah it looks multi-cam but it's it's
single
and that that goes to show uh the band
was very tight
uh they're they're very talented so they
play it like five times in a row without
you know
same tempo without [ __ ] it up boom
you know yeah that's
that's interesting and that's the way to
do it there
that was a good piece of this yeah you
play the song five times and you shoot
it from those different angles every
time and then that's how you get yeah
together boom that's so important that's
so so
so awesome okay all right so starting
off with
ganesh uh music video then evan
and then stereo jane so we're gonna play
that for you
now as examples of the art of video boom
[Music]
uh
[Music]
the green and chill i chase the money
back damn you have me for a second when
you say you long
on me
okay so that was ganesh
that was a fun well let me just say
something man we have a
lot to say about that one god yeah yeah
but
we do yeah okay let's show them is evan
bliss
i'm evan bliss and i design buildings
work that i've done has been recognized
by the american institute of architects
and
here in los angeles chapter also in the
chicago chapter
one national level aia awards hospitals
homes big buildings in major cities
warehouses manufacturing facilities
all those lessons that i've learned from
that is that you have to see
just over the hillside you have to see
that opportunity that waits
on the other side it used to be if you
wanted to
execute any sort of creative endeavor
by nature you had to have this really
large and expensive team that was all
kind of in-house and you just had to
have this incredible amount of resource
behind you to make that real but
i think there's much more powerful
models of how a creative
studio works that you could find in in
places like the technology industry
what and that was evan
all right and study stereo jane
lies
sheets that right me caught
up in the car so holy
face that all my sins like prey
my
[Music]
and
[Music]
take the pain away
[Music]
like
[Music]
i love those examples those are so good
thank you thank you oh my goodness okay
and i want to pull things up as we
literally unpack them in because first
of all
let's go to ganesh and i'm going to pull
up the visuals as we talk about it
so
okay so in ganesh
we have this we have this super
interesting part and we were kind of
talking about this a little bit before
we started too
where there's like a when she disappears
yeah where's the
bed yeah there it is it's coming it's
coming yeah right
here so that was fun um if you could see
the pictures in the background kind of
blow up as she disappears the front shot
she's not actually there
obviously that's that's a bunch of
effects and stuff so
uh to sell it more that's like a
practical
and cg sort of thing you can do is like
blow the pictures once you disappear so
she looks like she's actually
disappearing in the room when she's not
actually there
um and that it's the same for everything
like i would definitely recommend
like if you think if you see john
carpenter is the thing like the
practical effects like it's the same
story they're
they're uh you need practicals to make
cg look better and i'm not the greatest
cg editor but i did have fun and cg
computer graphics
yeah computer graphics yeah so i think
the practicals
of having the paper flow in the
background
sold it better than if they weren't
there
you know is now would it be fair
to say that you do
a there's like a similar cg
in a sense that happens
between this point what you're using
here
and what you're using kind of here right
and that would it be fair to say
something like
you because we're going to show some of
the stuff in the layering
um later but not to this exact video but
we'll show kind of what these techniques
look like a little bit
but is it something along the lines of
you take
like that like the picture
the still of her and then you
kind of bring it you you eliminate
everything in that image except her
yeah so for this shot and then you make
that opacity you bring the opacity down
make it more well it's different blend
modes and everything basically
you're right basically right we shot
this shot in particular on a green
screen
the um okay so it was on a green screen
yeah that's you key out the green and
then
what's left is her and that was an easy
shot at the left bring that down
and import that into this basically okay
so
so the last shot she was actually in the
bed the shot where that
she sat up in bed that was actually she
was sitting up in bed it's just a
different take
yeah yeah okay interesting and then you
just brought that
so you don't move the camera you
basically find everything that's the
same
in the shot and there's a way to get rid
of that so it looks yeah yeah so it's
like you screen it out
whoa so yeah that's so impressive
and uh if you look at the one of the
next shots there's uh
my first time really [ __ ] around with
motion control keep going
keep going so this shot um for example i
had
uh i mean it's it's a gimbal that you
can kind of program movement into
um so you can have it do the same thing
every time and i think we we recorded
just
a few angles where one take was
with ganesh and then the other take was
wish with the ghost girl
right so that's right and since they're
the exact same movements
camera movements and everything you can
overlay them
and do what i just talked about where
you just everything that's the same
frame you remove it yeah so she becomes
like you can
you can like make her disappear you can
do all kinds of effects
that i love i love exploring things like
that and yeah and that's that's
filmmaking yeah
super interesting yeah technologies okay
so a good thing to do in videography is
to take
the idea of us of a take
of the
what you're imagining creatively as the
actual
in this case is the guy that's in the
space
and then you take the second take of
where she's
also in the space and then you take a
blank slate of the same camera and then
the blank slate so i mean if you wanted
to you can make anything disappear in
the shot if you yeah
like anything like any character you
know wow yeah
that's great that was fun because i've
never really played with that before but
had fun with it so there's that and then
i thought another interesting thing that
i think
is becoming more popular in these as
well is that
you have things like these interesting
little transitions that occur
like those are cool i like those trends
that was uh
yeah i usually make my own transitions
but this
does the drop in you know that's a cool
one i think people are becoming more
they're here now especially in the rap
like that one
music videos and stuff and then this is
becoming more popular too sort of these
uh
like you can take the little phone shots
and there's those you know that
transition there
super interesting then there's sort of
this like
just overlays and overlays like that
those are cool
those are definitely trendy right yeah
to say the least
i mean super trendy yeah it's it's
gotten to the point where a lot of
music videos are exactly the same and uh
i've done a lot of music videos where
it's like
you go out and you're basically filming
the same video which is
you know i i wanted i you know i
respect it you know i see that it's the
quick way to do it and it
you know it sells right it's part of the
formula but it's
not the ideal uniqueness adding
uniqueness to aspects of the formula is
very important
right right and i try to do that it's
yeah yeah
yeah and then i really liked
in in evans i really liked
this kind of like look man there's a
chair here
and that it's literally opening to to
evan
walking up sitting down and then being
like
the first thing is just boom just right
there
i design buildings and then boom drops
right into like
my work has been featured here i've done
this
this and this like that's a really
strong format
yeah it's all about the hook in the
beginning and uh that was on purpose how
you could even see the lights
in the background and everything usually
that's big no no but that was
that was me kind of being like you know
i don't think yeah [ __ ] the rules kind
of
exactly that uniqueness which is what
you were saying
exactly yeah it ties back into that it's
like when the camera's in the shot
right that that kind of thing too like
on the two shot
you know you can see the over the
shoulder shot that we use oh yeah yeah
exactly
and so that's interesting that um yeah i
mean it doesn't matter people know that
there's a camera
because we have to do it for when we do
the writing examples
yeah and we can check out the kicks and
that like
yeah so there's that and then i really
liked also that
you know that will you will you also
just share with us
where are you getting like this um
content like i found that i know that
it's kind of that's b-roll i know that
one is because that's evans
but then but then this stuff right right
i would
yeah so where where do aspiring
uh videographers get high quality
b-roll that is not uh
capture stock video that's that they
purchase or license to
stock footage can be very expensive yeah
yeah but i don't like to pay for stock
footage so there's there's sites that
you can use i think off the top of my
head i can't remember the
the name but i think pond5 i just
basically uh
googled uh free software free stock
footage for
because you got the copyright free stuff
yeah it's definitely important to do you
don't want to get do more exactly
yeah but it's it's you know you can find
it just make sure it's copyright free
copyright free
is important and then make sure that
like youtube has the audio library which
i've been using a lot of audio libraries
it's pretty great
yeah and now it's all free um music
which is great and i've worked for a
bunch of places that use
uh different i mean they're all i mean
they're all good in their own respect
i wish i could remember the name i'm so
bad with names yeah but i wish i could
remember the name of there's one
um
i keep thinking audible but that's the
book yeah
but they they have stems so you can you
can find a song that you really like
and they'll um they'll have like an
option where you if you just want the
drums you can just have the drums
or like just the guitar just like the
vocals you know
and they're very high quality recordings
and this and that so
they're definitely expanding that that
style thing with with royalty free music
you know yes yes okay so then there's
there's that and then is there another
aspect
to evans that we should mention that you
think is important to share
evan made it so easy he's uh
he's definitely good in front of the
camera he's a talker yeah kind of keeps
going totally um that's another good
point
yeah is that the person the more inflow
they are
yeah yeah yeah exactly you want to
capture their essence and flow
right and if they if they're open about
that then it's great i mean some people
like like me i'm not used to being in
front of the camera i
will like shut down usually if there's a
camera pointing towards me i don't know
what to do
but uh but you know it's great seeing
somebody in front of the camera that can
actually rock it you know
which you have been this has been a
great flow we kind of worked our way
into you know
being in this flow right yeah totally
and you're really good at that too
thank you you kind of bring people in
and loosen them up
exactly and that's an important thing
for people that do video and photo
to be able to do in music production all
this type of stuff to loosen up
the yeah that alone is a talent it's a
skill it is a talent in weddings and
stuff too it's a good one
man i've had to come for like so many
brides they're like so
nervous yeah like this is the biggest
day of their lives
you know and so you have just like okay
you can do it you know
but it's definitely a skill actually
that's a great point that it's actually
useful for
people that are in the entertainment
industry in that sense to also have
practiced
meditation because then they can be
peaceful and they can calm the energy of
yeah
yeah exactly more grounded yep that's
good
maybe i should have meditated earlier
okay and then we have the the stereo
jane example
yes and this is really interesting
because you basically
shot this you said like five times
yeah different from all these they
played the song the same
same exact tempo i mean they had uh we
had a recording artist right there
recording it so this is a live
live recording you shot once from here
you shot once from here
shot one hand held a drum cam a couple
times i mean
you know wow bass and then there was
also the same day recorded
an acoustic set um that i don't think is
released yet but
but uh yeah and then and then you just
in the layers you just cut between them
as
to match them all up that used to be a
very hard job but now it's a way
and now because you use software to
match them up like that
it's amazing what software do you use to
match with premiere yeah just literally
highlight
the audio tracks right click and
synchronize right click
on the audio tracks and click
synchronize synchronize and then they'll
just
they'll just line up at the bottom
there's an option to click audio like
you can synchronize
different things but i click audio and
then it's perfect every time pretty much
that's awesome to the frame to the frame
it's great it's awesome like i remember
back
i used to make lyric videos it used to
take
so long oh my god to line it up yeah
line everything up different
different uh wavelengths interesting but
and there's software for i know
matching like for example when i do
on the road interviews usually i'm
bringing like the zoom h6
right with me and then i have to bring
that in the camera audio too
yeah and then then you can do that right
click sync
but usually i'm sometimes i'm just
trying to make sure that it's exactly on
frame and like there's software that
helps with the like
movement also of right the mouth and
stuff like that yeah yeah
that's crazy and this is a really good
this is another really good
there's like in a sense we're
highlighting the art of video from many
different angles because you have
ganesha's a much more um
it's leveraging a lot more of kind of
like the modern
not only different genre of music but
it's also it's leveraging a lot more of
those modern
transitions we were talking about and a
lot more of that those
uh that cg computer graphics
stuff and whereas in stereo jane it's a
lot more of that classic
set yeah i love both styles a lot of
time um so
i kind of you know you have to know what
to look for
and um strive for that like if you look
in the in the stereo jane one
there's a lot of soft tungsten lighting
rather than in the ganesh one there's a
lot of hard
you know daylight lighting so those it's
just a different that's a good point
yeah different
different vibes and in evans it was also
that daylight
evans had a lot of daylight and i liked
how that's also this
juxtaposed with music videos is this
highlighting of
like evan's expression his aromatic
flower expression is what you as what
you did this is so easy to catch though
you know
yeah you're good you're good yeah you're
good that's good it's so easy to catch
with evan because he's just an honest
guy
you know he's just real real dude shout
out evan
shout out being real hella real yeah and
so are you and zach that's pretty norcal
man the crew is
the helmer hello real hell yeah i know
hella is a very norcal yes right
i know i'm so happy i picked that up
yeah i know
yeah and you're you mentioned omar
omar's man marsa homie
um i mean the click is
is really strong and it's growing and
it's growing to take over
this is only one nodal cluster because
there's yeah
there's many that were overlapping and
connecting and
flowering totally this is gonna be the
we're gonna own los angeles
we're gonna help awaken we're gonna wake
up yeah exactly
exactly and inclusively stakehold
everybody exactly yeah that was it yeah
totally transparent yeah speaking of
stakeholding um
i wanted to say it bothers me when
somebody like like the networking thing
like we all help each other out you know
but i i i i don't like
when somebody a friend helps another
person out
and does it without giving them
something back
you know like at least like you have
it's uh you help them out they help you
out
or they help you out you help them out
or monetarily you know it's not wrong to
give your friends money if they're
helping you out
if there's a budget give them money you
know totally i've worked for free
way too many times for people that i
would call friends you know
and uh it's not you know i wouldn't do
that to anybody man if
you come on with me i'm paying you if
you set up a light stand you get paid
for it
that's right yeah inclusive stakeholding
is is exactly that
yeah there's always the endeavors where
it's like
wanting to like i was kind of going
through this
a little bit yesterday as an idea but a
good analogy to draw for where we're at
right now
would be like if today
you were told that you could go back to
2015
when uh and be an intern for
joe rogan a lot of people would go and
do it totally
but today it's interesting for me i'm
struggling
with identifying finding people that
want to come on an
intern but that's because a lot of
people don't see
where we're going to be in 2025 right
and so i'm trying to hook people up and
have them be young jamie's at [ __ ]
good
times in the growth process but it's
hard to sell that vision to to other
people and whatnot and
in this case i would do things like i
mean
to go and like be with you know
like i think it'd be very powerful to
sit in
like with maybe gary vaynerchuk or
someone for a day
to like be unpaid but to be helping and
to be learning
so there's that powerful sort of like
surround yourself with really powerful
nodes even if it's unpaid there's that
balance
but then also it's balanced with like yo
be that person that inclusively
stakeholds everybody in the sense of
like
when there is a budget
like pay people really well especially
when they deserve it when they're
performing really well
and then what's going to happen is a lot
of flowers and blossoming
exactly it'll all it'll all kind of
sprout your field that you've grown and
everybody's working together as a team
rather than just one for their self yeah
yeah yeah yeah so let's
do let's do a little breakdown as well
so
okay yeah so walk us through like this
looks
crazy this is the you know the bottom
right corner for those that don't know
that's what
premiere that's the timeline that's the
timeline
so and then what you have in that
timeline is you have
what looks like again if we just think
about it like
whether it's what zeb was doing by
showing us the
layers in music production or in this
case kyle's showing us
the layers in video production which
also includes audio
itself but the audio is not you take
that final audio track of all those like
20 layers and then you bring that into
one and put that in the video
um yeah which yeah and that's uh yeah
basically
and a lot of times you'll be cutting
audio just like you've seen a video
that's right um but yeah this is a this
is a short this is actually a short-term
project i did this in last few days
um not actually sure it's not it's not
released yet so don't you know
mute it and everything but this is uh oh
yeah it is it's it is muted
okay yeah it's completely muted and we
can play it
so they're so they're not hearing
anything okay
and why don't you walk us through it
yeah this is just uh i was showing you
the um
basically the how premiere works and how
it looks with an edited project
and you can scrub through the timeline
and then you know
you can go to uh there's like different
tabs at the top basically and i'll do
some color grading here because that's
part of that's one of my favorite parts
um
yeah i don't know where i did it but
anyway there's yeah i go to the color
tab and then i turn off the color that i
did on there
and you could see you could just see the
difference and that's part of like
that's one of the most satisfying things
in film like editing is the color
grading yes
because here i am like like just messing
with like tweaking the exposure and
everything that's the original that's
out of camera
oh no that's what it looked like out of
camera oh
which flat is good right you can do a
lot of editing with flat and that's with
the lut
but interesting so you capture and flat
to do all that
yeah so so there's the flat flat has the
highest bit depth you can
introduce yeah yeah pull it out i mean
these are that's cool
so it's like most raw raw is the most
exactly flat is most raw okay yeah okay
and uh
yeah wow
wow okay so so is it fair then to say
something along the lines of like
what you're what you're sort of doing
is you're in a sense you're capturing
what does that even
mean like what does it mean when
uh like how does how does capturing
something
flat or raw how does that
what does that do like what would that
be like with this
like instead of what we have how would
we
set these to capture raw i know we're
not doing this here
but i'm just saying for for as an
example like if i am to go and capture a
shot of
the ocean or the trees or somebody's
face
um or capture a video of any of those
things how do i set my
camera to capture it raw or flat rule
number one
how do i draw it out yeah shoot in
manual at all times
yeah manual um you know i mean like uh
white balance and stuff you can kind of
you kind of play with but um
yeah shooting manual and usually dslrs
now
are they do raw and you got to choose
the color science that you want the
um i guess the look is is what it is but
yeah there's there's a ton of different
things you can do they just shoot raw
shoes in manual yeah and manual and uh
yeah there's just some mode called raw
this is uh uh this mode is uh uh
v log that's right i was on the tip of
my vlog v-log
yeah so panasonic gh5s is what we shot
this with and v-log
is the flattest grade possible so the
flatter
with with raw like you have a lot of bit
depth right this is basically
how much you can edit in one image how
much color information you can pull out
okay and with the the flatter the image
uh
in certain cases as long as there's the
bit depth for you to play with
then you're expected to play with that
right you're expecting to pull out the
depth meaning that it's closer to
something that's maybe like a black
white and gray that you can then draw
more color from so the higher the bit
depth the blacker your images can be
if it's right in the middle then you can
you have more control basically over the
colors
okay versus if you cap it in color you
have way
less control over the colors versus when
you cap it in black
or that that bit depth you can draw out
however much
it depends on appropriate the bit depth
right so if you're if you're shooting
let's say photography for example if
you're taking
jpegs with your camera immediately stop
doing that don't do that don't take
jpegs don't take jpegs take
raw images if you have a camera that's
images yeah yeah yeah
raw images yep um because you get way
more control uh
because of the color space in lightroom
for you after lightroom yeah
photoshop does it too it's uh for some
reason runs slow on my computers
with photoshop but i mean i don't know
why you'd really use photoshop for that
because that's what lightroom is built
for
um so i'm importing raw images into
lightroom and then i'm doing like in
premiere it's called like lumetri
yeah exactly so lumetri's in lightroom
too but if you have a way more
way more leroy leeway in in lightroom
right so you can completely change the
look of an image
and uh same with uh same with video you
know you can do a lot of color editing
and
ideally what you shoot you should shoot
to edit
and what you shoot shouldn't be like
anything close to what
you have released that's a such an
interesting perspective
i guess it also depends then on um
if it's what like
project it's for creatively because
for the ones that you're describing um
it makes total sense because you're
taking
it all so you're shooting where it looks
nothing like the final
and you're doing it all in post whereas
for
me maybe with like right now with my
caliber of like
on off-site interviews where when i do
those
that then it's really just like lav mics
into the zoom and then just setting up
the cameras on
if i do manual i do but usually it's
something like auto and just making sure
that the lighting is straight right
and it like depends on what you're doing
because i'm just switching between two
shots and i'm talking as
a camera you know operator there has to
be someone operating on the camera
you know and yeah if you if you're
setting a camera up to
do an interview in front of the camera
like these for example you're definitely
going to want to
have automatic settings just in case we
do stuff exactly right remove and all
this stuff yeah yeah totally
and the color you know the white balance
and stuff like that automatic everything
interesting so it totally then depends
but most of the time
when you're trying to take things into
post shoot your
photos in raw bring them into lightroom
rule number one rule number one photos
especially man
yeah and then in video you want it to be
where you can
take draw out as much of the color as
possible yeah yeah
that's that's that's also a good point
because you know i'm not thinking of
uh actually running like i do run and
gun but i'm always on camera right run
and gun if i were to do the interviews i
wouldn't shoot
just manual everything like focus and
everything you'd have to
oh yeah make automatic that's right yeah
and now automatic autofocus is getting
crazy um
in the recent years it's pretty good
because you know you never had that
before you just have to set the aperture
all the way up and
make everything in focus which doesn't
look as good nope
now you can have autofocus and it tracks
your face perfectly
yeah forever i hope to i hope to get
that uh implemented into some of the
existing uh technological
systems like so because these guys
because
they're really strong for
what they're what we're purposing for
them for right now the existing camera
system
these are jvc ptz pan tilt zoom robotic
camera so that
i'm not even controlling them so would
it follow me if i got up and walked away
and so that's the next
feature is the um the tracking and then
the feature
after that which we were beginning to
describe
is that we don't have yet the setting
where
it will take because we've had this
feedback several times
is the setting where it um does the
um like follows you nope nope nope it's
the
um i have the word one moment nope i
have i have the moment one word it's
one moment it's the
bokeh boca yeah the very blurriness in
the background basically
yeah so that we've had that feedback
several times where
the bokeh you would have this blurriness
all in the background so that it would
basically draw out the salience of
kyle's face
right and so that's something we've
gotten feedback for so that's another
thing with the camera
separation is important exactly and then
the other one is that eventually we'll
have the artificial intelligence
algorithms that then do things like
take the existing stream between cameras
and that they as my
stream of vocals end and your starts
switches yeah and then when we say pull
up
uh you know the specific thing that we
were just looking up a moment ago
on the search engine that then we can
pull
up content as we talk about it to do
fact checking and right so that's like
it's like hey google pull this up
let's do it yeah exactly or it's auto or
auto
recognizes you say like a keyword
exactly and it'll listen to what you're
saying i mean we're not far off man
we're not far off that's going to happen
sooner or later we're not going to
need any cameramen at all it's kind of a
wild thing because now they have throw
the drone up i have yeah exactly no i
have
they do have drones that follow you i
also have a gimbal where if you mount
if you mount your phone you need your
phone to do it but if you mount your
phone to the top of it
it will track you and it'll it'll follow
you around so you can
basically have a full 360 shot yeah i
saw that with
ron our our uh producer director in the
bay area he showed me that one that's a
good one
it's really just follows you around put
the phone on the gimbal and walk around
and
you just talk to yourself you know and
you have what looks like a professional
professional cameraman
yeah yeah super interesting and that's
what that's the same given like just
like
that the drone follows and it'll fly
through trees and your trees
go through all that while you're skiing
and [ __ ] yes
yes stuff like that and the same thing
with the like you've heard the
mandalorian
the disney plus uh star wars
show right uh mandalore mandalorian yeah
with the baby yoda
oh the viral the way they shot that
is crazy i mean they've been doing
similar things for a long time but they
took it to the next level
where uh instead of a green screen like
you know a lot of this a lot of it's cg
blah blah blah they actually utilized a
giant
lcd oh now i know what you're talking
about that spins
with the cam moves with the camera so
it's like connected visually to the
camera i forgot that now why
why are people choosing to do
the are people choosing to do these
massive lcd screen environments
and they look like yeah let's definitely
pull it up
super interesting actually
before before the rona hit i got invited
to
visit the mandalorian set
nah you know and then everything
went to [ __ ]
but hopefully i'll just kind of come
back from that i'll take definitely
gonna come back yeah what would be what
would be a good thing to
search to find that like i'm trying to
find it
it's kind of a little bit like just men
yeah that's kind that's basically what
it is we're getting yeah we're kind of
getting that we're not seeing it on the
screen
but no yeah we're gonna switch that up
yeah there you go
so but they're even bigger i mean we're
talking like full
full 360 full 360. um
you know the perspective that it's in 3d
space so this looks like it's kind of
just a picture
that might move with the camera as you
dolly around it but
when the mandalorian the way they did it
was it's connected the camera in such a
way
where you move the camera and the whole
background it's really trippy to watch
i'd check out like youtube or something
m-a-n-d-a-l-o-r-i-a-n
there it is like this one right yeah
whoa i know this one's so crazy
and they they have it half like i was
saying earlier like practicals like when
we blew the
sheets on the windows they have the the
ground like they
they build practically inside the room
so this is crazy it has interaction with
the
with the things it's the craziest set
you know
oh my goodness so we're saying let's
let's put it this way so
we have
okay so we have kind of like levels so
one of the levels is we just go and we
capture something with the camera
the next level is that maybe we do
something like we add
green screens or we add like what we're
talking about with some cg
right in one of your videos play with
that
and then we have this sort of like
like either a hundred percent cgi
which is becoming more common or
um yeah you have people that wear those
like
full suits with sensors that then right
you take the human in but then it's a
completely
cg environment
and then yeah and then there's also just
the human in a completely cg environment
yeah exactly yeah yeah and then then
there's this which is
that instead of generating a cg
environment in like post
what you do is you basically generate
the cg environment on this
360 degree lcd screen right
and it reacts with the camera movement
so the pearson
you can do handheld in this room and
it'll make it look realistic
you know how the parallax of everything
like if you move your head things move
differently different ways
you can move the camera and it'll react
as if
whoa so it's synced the camera is synced
with the
360 lc screen yeah and the things the
items and stuff in the background like
say there's hallways or whatever you can
basically have a camera moving through
the hallway
and you know handheld the walking
movements
that you would be doing now what's the
what's the
benefit of doing it this way versus the
cgi a lot cheaper i imagine this way i
imagine
yeah because it's one set and you can
you can do whatever you want on it you
know
and i hear a lot about this there's a
there's there's a few different things
that they're doing right now like in
manhattan beach somewhere i haven't
placed
location i'll let you know when i find
out but there's like a football field
sized green screen yeah whoa with
cameras like red cameras mounted
about every like meter three meters or
whatever on the walls
and you can do anything like like you
know the matrix the original matrix
where
neos dodging the bullets yeah that was
done with a bunch of dslrs
that yeah in today's day and age
wouldn't you know they're not they're
like canon
whatever whatever cause but but yeah you
could do that with reds
in a football field side stadium and
basically turn on each camera
and have like a slow-motion matrix style
thing and a huge
enormous green screen space so that
would be the most expensive like
way to do it this would be probably
middle ground you know
the lcd screen curved lcd screens exist
for consumers
like it's not it's not super this is
really interesting as part of the future
i would also say that kind of the next
step above this
is kind of like literally immersing
yourself indistinguishably in the three
space
itself right like in a completely
indistinguishable virtual environment
and like
that's metaphysically what we
hypothesize this
is this experience and this reality yes
yeah yeah that's
kind of the yeah exactly we can get a
little into the
those benefits i mean yeah you think
about like like buddhists
um they believe right as buddhists
they believe that when you live your
life the right way
you reincarnate it until you live your
life the right way and then and then you
go on to the next level
yeah that reminds me of mario man it's
like you jump into the
the hole in the ground so many times and
then you figure out a way to jump over
the hole
right yeah and you're on the next level
yeah yeah and same with the
uh like vishnu the the hindus believe
that like
all this is vishnu's dream right like
that's another it's virtual reality man
that's right
that's true i think that's right and
there's there's there's
like you look up into space and we don't
know what the [ __ ] up there it's all
numbers like the what we have now is
just
basically what we think it is you know
and there's
there's it's all math so anything can
happen man you know
right right yeah i like how you brought
in you i like how you brought in the
eastern philosophies
and spiritual traditions because i
completely
agree that you have this process of
doing things like whether you call it
the
noble eightfold path or whether you call
the ten commandments
in the abrahamic tradition it literally
doesn't matter they're basically trying
to just get you to channel
only the highest possible morality
ethics
and your own suffering and the suffering
of others around you
and then what happens is that
you literally become
god consciousness and then what happens
is that
at that point you
have such a transcendent experience you
like transcend and
include like the human body like you
anchor that
in your spirit in your energy and you in
physicalism so everything you affect in
the physical world is
that butterfly effect of that highest
possible morality ethic but also that
you
transcend in the sense of like you've
transcended and included your ego
you're no longer in that obsessive
compulsive
self-dealing state of existence and then
also you even transcend and include
the the
obsession with nationalism or
obsession with like skin color or things
like that
you're basically transcending it's greed
um
affliction and and uh ignorance right
that's not reflection
that's the second one a version yeah a
version yes yes yes yes right
yeah that's right yeah that's right my
brother yeah i'm all about that
and then the dream that like you're
mentioning the idea of
recursion or the idea of as above so
below
as well right is that
the same way that we go into a
dream it's so funny as above so below we
go into a dream
once a day and that
during those eight hours what's
occurring is that we are literally
simulating a reality
where we are both in our own mind where
we are both
the spirit of the consciousness and we
are the physicalism of the environment
that we've simulated for the spirit to
be inside of
so we simulate both the consciousness
and we simulate the actual environment
for it right
in the same in the same dream same dream
reality
and so then the hypothesis is that as
above so below
we are infinite consciousness we
simulated these finite
realities for us to sit in as a
finite separate conscious entity and
that
we engage in these physical realities
for consciousness to undergo the process
of exploring what all these different
tastes of experience right are it's like
it's like a huge storm over an ocean
with uh with uh tornadoes touching down
each one of us is a tornado right the
mass of consciousness is the storm
right and we're touching down uh there's
also the egg i think is a really good
example of that like if you look up the
egg
on youtube oh yeah the shorts yeah yeah
yeah yeah andy weir that's that's the
same point and then and then kirk's
gazota is the animation studio that
right yeah
amazing animation they're so well done
they're like pixar level in my opinion
yeah exactly and andy did a great job
writing that story yeah
yeah fantastic that's a that's a good
example and i like the
storm and tornadoes we also have the
whirlpool analogies and other one little
whirlpools of consciousness
yeah is another one yeah there's these
analogies are really powerful because
they help communicate metaphysics in
relatable ways for kids
and for adults and that's me i'm
honestly just starting to do
this stuff me too i'm i'm trying my best
to be as eli 5
as possible with this stuff yeah but
this
is so fascinating because what we're
literally talking about right now and
what's the best word for these again the
360
lcd environments or what's the best word
for it
uh indeed i wish i knew that let's say
360l
environments okay so that these
environments are
like our train of thinking is super
interesting here because we're talking
360 uh lcd environments then we're
talking
you know using unity and unreal and
building reality three space virtual
realities
exactly and then now we're and then
we're talking about
literally what our reality is because as
we go more and more to these things that
we're communicating
we immerse ourselves more and more into
these environments that you're seeing
here on screen and that these
indistinguishable worlds like you see in
ready player one in the matrix and all
stuff
that more and more we're gonna awaken to
the fact that
this already is that yeah and we're
undergoing this process of
exploring infinite states of qualia
infinite phenomenological experiences
for consciousness to undergo yeah i
think the probability
of us being in a virtual reality
outweighs the probability of us
actually being here you know
you know what i mean it's kind of weird
to think about that
and to me it's the same thing which is
super interesting
like there's a funny thing like we're
always trying to like separate
things like science and spirituality or
base reality and virtual reality
they're the [ __ ] same thing yeah
that's i love viewing it that way it's
all about your experience right
yeah it's all the experience you have as
a person
slash imaginated entity entity
entity yeah you know entities a good
word for to you massaro has been kind of
all-encompassing and
the law of one raw has a really good
mind-body spirit complex
is a good way to say yeah yeah i know
it's a good way to say it mind-body
spirit complex that is a good one
yeah that's what it is the law of one
by raw book i should read that i'll uh
i'll send you to
um actually we can pull it up because
it's i think it's that profoundly
important for people
that we'll go ahead and pull it up so
it is
i can't i can't wait for you to get greg
bro we are gonna
rock it with greg i'm so pumped to have
him on um thank you for that intro
i'm so pumped to have greg he's a great
dude fascinating
yeah and it's probably gonna happen
right after new year's we'll also send
him
um this as well so he kind of knows that
the homies are
are ready we're ready for him so this
is um this is
law of one dot info okay
okay so that's the url for everyone law
of one dot info
com law of one dot info now when you get
here
this is law of one the idea is generally
that you had raw raw
is a this was a process that was
undergone
a series of 106 conversations
called sessions
between don elkins a professor of
physics and ufo investigator
and raw speaking through carla
ruckert wow and so
raw states that if they are a
six-density social memory complex that
formed on venus
about 2.6 million years billion years
ago and they are humble messengers of
the law of one
and that they previously tried to spread
this message in ancient egypt with mixed
results
so wow and so what the idea is is that
if you go down here and you begin
browsing by category
there's archetypal mind balancing before
the veil cosmology earth history
of meditation law of one higher self
pyramids teachings
original thought ufo science sexual
energy transfer and all this stuff have
you heard about the um
the fbi i think no cia on fbi
but they're playing with uh uh psychics
you hear about that like they're they're
kind of when the cia there's a there's a
document i don't know if it's real or
not which one
but uh they're they're talking about how
they they got a
a psychic and they said go to this
coordinate
like go to these coordinates and it was
the mars is like coordinates on mars
and they said to go back like two
billion years or whatever sure
and it's it's just crazy like yeah
it's i love i would love to believe it
well this is the thing is that
we we have to have a high
amount of openness to new things and
experience
but we have to not it has to be balanced
because you have to not
let in like oh i'm gonna be open to the
new experience
of rebirthing slavery like let's do it
you know and so
and the same thing kind of where
somebody can in a sense they can have
their own subjective hallucinative
experience
of doing something like i astral
projected to this star system and i
yeah and i and i underwent this process
and it's like
this is excellent you can have whatever
beautiful subjective conscious
experiences you want
absolutely my next step would be instead
of
instead of having people say you're a
liar that's bs
instead of that i would say bless the
person
and the next thing would be the next
thing would be why don't we do our best
to structure
some sort of scientific method around
pushing beyond the edge of what is
known by us right and that's exactly
that's
that's it that's basically it so when
you take being done when you take uh
bob monroe and the gateway when you take
edgar cayce's work
when you take the idea of just
channeling in general
astral projection autobody experiences
near-death experiences
what entheogens do to us with unleashing
the divine within
what does that mean who knows i'm gonna
look all this stuff up beautiful and
hopefully other people as well because
i'm still a student of
all of this as well what does non-dual
states of conscious experience mean
and how can we sort of anchor ourselves
in the highest
morality and ethic of buddha or christ
or lao tzer confucius level
consciousness
but flower that out on an individual
artistic
expression to the world around us on a
moment-to-moment
basis to ourselves our families our
communities the world
how can i still make cool videos but
live in a state of nondual
peace bliss consciousness and so that's
what i hypothesize a symphonic
consciousness which is what we were
talking about a little bit earlier right
which is where you feel
both the ocean and you feel the
whirlpool or the storm and the tornado
okay
at the same time because you are that
unique storm or that unique
whirlpool you're the unique sorry
tornado or
yes exactly and that you're an artist
and you will resonate this most as
people like you and me is that we're
artists
and that the more people think of
themselves as artists
that's when they realize that they have
a unique melody
or instrument that they're playing in
the symphony in that oneness
and that your unique gift that you're
bringing in the world that's
self-actualization
and self-realization is when you realize
the oneness the unity right
yeah yeah it hasn't happened yet
it's bound to happen though you know i
mean yeah
that's what we were talking about
earlier with the um like the buddhists
and
like the next level and everything it's
yeah i think it's fascinating but i
really don't know much about
much about it we need to actually invest
time as a civilization right into the
investigation of truth
consciousness awareness
the nature of reality because what we
have is we have a culture of
mindfulness right we have yeah i like
that we have a culture where like sad
guru says you know you spend 10 years
learning a language but you want to be
enlightened in five minutes
right right and so we need to humble
ourselves and realize that you know
i spent 10 straight months
from the beginning of 2020 until october
before moving to l.a
alone alone and studying the 1000 most
uncommon geniuses that have ever lived
abstracting out a meta pattern studying
the world's perennial spirituality
studying the world's cutting-edge
sciences and putting it all into
artistic eli
5 which then gave me a lattice work
for me to move forward right as a
conceptual so you build a foundation out
of what you
learn yourself you know and that's the
whole passion thing like you would
nobody would be able to do that kind of
thing like i wouldn't be a filmmaker
still
if i wasn't passionate about it the
north star you know and the fact that
you
you do that and then you you use that
and build your own yes
stepping stones yes that's that's a huge
thing you know and it's it's uh
it's not easy but it's this is something
and this is why we have people
like when there's two things here when
we talk on the program
what at least is happening is maybe you
know kyle's getting
his moment of exposure to this and maybe
other people are as well
the idea that okay what if
i literally blocked out a week of my
calendar
and i literally did a deeper
investigation
into what you know what is advaita
vedanta what is the direct path the
non-dual direct path
or what is the theravada buddhism
vipassana style what
i haven't read the old testament new
testament maybe i should just give those
a quick
read maybe i should watch you know
jordan peterson's dissemination of them
in a psychological perspective as well
maybe maybe i should go in and dance the
african vodoon tradition maybe i should
go sit in some of the
uh entheogenic ceremonies that occur in
the native american tradition
and maybe if we sample those things for
at least
some periods of time a week or more and
if you can dedicate even more time to
truth that's even better
and then what happens is you basically
re-baseline your consciousness
to those higher states and then
everything you do from there in terms of
your
artistic expression your
self-actualization process
becomes way more efficient you become
way
you become way more in service to others
because you realize the
the self in the other and then what
happens is that
you get more clients more peaceful
people around you
more self-actualized people around you
you climb to your goals faster
and this is the second point that i was
going to say which is that you know i've
been sharing a bit
about our animated series and 2021
chimps that we're really excited for
and in 2021 portalist the anthology
series that we're working on as well
and it's interesting because kyle is one
of those people that i would probably
say is one of the more
higher up visionaries around the
videography space that actually
understands what the art
of the portalist would actually entail
in making
and so i would say that what happens is
that the more that you
become self-realized the more that you
strive
in a framework for self-actualization
loose right again loose but
a framework what happens is you
naturally gravitate people
in so in this case it's like kyle's like
portals is pretty interesting this is
something that
i could potentially see as being
something popular that i might be able
to get behind
and what happens is every time somebody
comes on the show i become more
gravitated toward them
now i understand more about what kyle's
been showing us his wisdoms
especially around all this insanity
around the layering and the photography
video
videography it all ties in it all ties
in
and so i'm being gravitated by you and
all these other guests that come on the
show into your worlds
and in doing so other people that watch
the show become gravitated into your
worlds
into my world and that more and more
hopefully we're co-creating
that more beautiful world our hearts
know as possible
right that's pretty much the essence of
this i love it man i think that's
that's great you're kind of absorbing uh
the the vibrations of everybody that
comes on set and
obviously everybody you talk to in
general like very good conversationalist
and uh you know what you're doing and i
can i can you love to learn you'll have
to give information
yes yeah i learned a lot through this
this thing my mind is definitely more
open than it was when i
came here in the first place you know i
love it i appreciate that
thanks for that yeah thanks for the
recognition and the love and
i feel the same way i'm such a child
sponging up the knowledge that is
communicated
it's a big aroma of flower and it's a
cross-pollination
right exactly yeah and don't change if
you if you think of growing
up don't do it i love it don't do that
retain that child like awe
yeah yeah i mean you can do taxes and
stuff but oh my god
yeah yeah world you know um
okay i mean we pretty much touched on
everything that i wanted to touch on in
the later part of the show which was
perfect
um i love it i mean some of the last
things that we could probably talk about
are um the fact that we both see
a very deeply uh independent
freelance creative scene emerging
especially with the decentralization
technologies yeah absolutely i mean um i
used to want to join a union
uh but at this point [ __ ] that no it's
basically
an expensive club now and you don't they
don't
you know it's just my opinion don't you
know it's my opinion but
[ __ ] the unions um they everything's
going independent uh everybody i talk to
agrees
and it's uh and it opens up a whole new
world
you know basically you can do anything
there's there's
uh politics uh in the way i work are
like i shown them i don't do like with
big with big uh
groups and stuff like that's what i've
been talking about like you have to work
together
as as friends as a as a machine you know
and
as a pr as a group of problem solvers
rather than a group of separate um you
know
uh a group of separate groups trying to
make one thing
because in my experience it's it makes
it more difficult and
it's a lot more troublesome that way you
know what i mean yep
that made any sense yes yes like like
art directors sometimes aren't allowed
to talk to
uh producer producers sound guys can't
talk to that that's right
that's right and it's like what's the
point you know you're trying to make one
thing
yes and if you can't talk to each other
about it then how is it gonna
turn into anything okay and this is
where the synthesis i think happens
between
the heterarchy the flat the
decentralization with the hierarchy
and there's a really important synthesis
here because you can't have the data
silos that you're speaking about right
now which suck
when the audio engineer can't actually
talk to the dp
yeah about what's happening and there's
data silos
right yes and then what you want is you
want the interoperability
of data just like between like facebook
and google
and baidu and tencent and stuff around
the planet right just like we want to do
that
and just like the way that cells
communicate
in inter cellularly in the body yeah and
the same way that as a
you know as a country's that's why we
use barges to ship
goods in containers we're all in across
ocean you know we're in contact with
each other i think that's the name of
the game
it's the oneness that has to happen on
set and yes
and also with the hierarchy in the sense
of like the dp
should be able to because the audio
engineer might have five
ten whatever years of experience but
maybe hasn't actually been the dp for
five or ten years like the dp has been
right
director producer
so then in this example it would be you
want to decentralize as much as you can
to get all of the synthesis of the most
data points about the knowledge but then
you still
want in terms of some sort of a
hierarchical decision to be made about
the data from the person that's most
synthetic right the data so you can't
just top with a hierarchical
system you have to have a little bit of
that because
you know like like there are certain
visionary directors
that you know a lot of the movies that
are my favorite movies wouldn't exist
now
without them you know without any i mean
no movies would really exist without a
director
it would be a [ __ ] mess it would be a
nightmare that's right trying
to make something that's a great way to
put it a solid vision
i think it's very important to have a
solid vision that's the hierarchy but
but think about this reality in this
reality we
are the actors actresses
and we are also the directors and
producers in a co-creative fashion
right so there's no hierarchical the
hierarchical one isn't like an
individual human
it's what in mathematics we call a
strange attractor it's what a complex
system evolves towards
and so we ourselves program that into
the reality but in a non-deterministic
way
we programmed it in a quantum mechanical
free will
way right and so then we're the actors
and actresses but it is still going on
the stage
towards the goal and the goal the star
is the recursion so it's the metaverse
that we were talking about when we go
inward
into those indistinguishable virtual
infinite worlds to taste new conscious
experiences
that's the godhead star but our pa
excuse me but our path on getting there
has been very fluid in water
sand in the sense of we could have you
know
it's not like the uk had to
you know ship people from europe to
north america
to begin taking over the united states
you know 250 years ago right this didn't
have to happen this way or like world
war ii could have played out completely
differently yeah absolutely yeah yeah so
anyway
so it's a messy process like i said like
making anything good is a messy process
sometimes so
yeah yeah and so we still can play
in this messy process actually i like
thinking like it's an artistic it's kind
of like
it's a big white yeah yeah it is in a
sense it's messy and harmonic and
yeah it's that's what i think timing
back to movies i think that's what
they're
losing nowadays you know like like that
with the
the way things are done in like let's
say
i did like an mtv show uh like reality
tv show and everything
i would think reality tv would have
would be more loose than
like okay now you go here and you just
say these lines in action
but it's not it's like it's exactly what
it is yeah
yeah so i think the way to do it is like
i said
uh independent is coming back
for sure yeah yeah i love that i love
that last question
what is oh god oh jesus
your favorite food
um well right now i
am feeling a chipotle burrito so that
sounds really good
would you say that that's kind of your
go-to
not always not always i think it's uh
specific i have very different tastes um
it depends on if i want to make
something or buy something i
i love uh i make really good scrambled
eggs
yeah uh with the caramelized onions you
know i love that
yeah um bacon i i have to ask a couple
questions here okay
first of all is um okay let's start with
when you go
out right chipotle
tell me what you get in your chipotle it
depends if i'm feeling uh
if i'm feeling risky i'll get a bowl
like a burrito bowl and then i'll get
the chips
and you dip the chips and that's right
that's right yeah but you gotta get this
hot sauce like
i don't know for some reason that's all
about the you like the spicy i do like
the spicy but i'm kind of a [ __ ] when
it comes to spiciness
yeah i i'm i'm a medium yeah yeah yeah
but i love the paint you know
the paints i'm a little masochistic in
terms of that but
yeah i'll complain about it but i'll be
loving it secretly
um but you know burritos you can't go
wrong with the burrito
you know brazilians are classic we'll
skip over some of the other details now
take me to the scrambled eggs scrambled
eggs okay so this is when you make stuff
i like i love making scrambled eggs as
well
and there's so many awesome toppings to
put in i like how you pick caramelized
onions
huge fan of that as well great
question in scrambled eggs first of all
egg choice i think is very important a
lot of people don't realize how
important egg choice is
one time one of my friends told me that
if you want to be eating um high quality
eggs
what you should be doing is spending at
least 50 cents
on each egg and i thought that was a
very interesting
sense on each other on each egg so so he
says in the u.s at least right in our
yeah and so here's an idea i like vital
farms
they're a good one um and they're i
think they're about six bucks or so for
12
right so it's about 50 cents an egg but
you can tell because when you crack one
of
the vital farms eggs it's literally the
yolks orange
you know it's it's literally fresh and
tastes
super good and then if you compare that
to one of the eggs that costs like five
or ten cents an egg
right it's nowhere near as delicious and
so i'm curious interesting
you know i'm uh i just go for the
biggest eggs i could find because i'm
the largest boy you like size i like
size yeah but
honestly i've had small eggs that are
delicious too the size size doesn't
matter
in eggs
and then so are you now the next
question is when you scramble
right are you scrambling in a bowl
before
you go of course or and then are you are
you adding any
milk or milk cream is great you do just
a
little bit of a tad of milk or cream uh
i do milk when i have because i barely
ever have cream yeah but i mean
cream makes it even fluffier fluffier
that has the fluff factor of it and then
you add salt
and pepper pepper usually just salt and
pepper yeah occasionally
there's there's you know i tried uh
the other day i tried i added some butt
rub
yeah like it there's a lot of salt in it
so i'd forgo the salt and then add the
butter up exactly
uh it's pretty good i'm not gonna and
then you cook the caramelized onions
before
ahead of time ahead of time and then at
the end when the eggs are almost done
you add the caramelized onions
to it yeah yeah usually ideally ideally
you would uh
cook some bacon in the pan beforehand oh
and then that would get the grease
and then you can otherwise otherwise i
use butter if i butter
yeah bacon yeah but i see you add bacon
to
the eggs on this side on the side yeah
i'm not i'm not
i don't chop bacon up that's
sacrilegious you know i just
the whole slice of bacon yeah you get
the crispiness yeah delicious
now do you like under cooking medium
cooking or
or well done i like parts of my bacon
uh crispy yeah i think crispy bacon is
one of the best things ever but
you also have to balance it out it's
like it's like too much of a good thing
is not really again it's the middle path
yeah exactly
exactly so you gotta get those little
bubbles where the bacon is not totally
done exactly exactly and those are the
best that's the best i know
yeah i love it i'm okay that's a wrap
folks that's it
that's it my brother kyle thank you that
was so [ __ ] fantastic
thank you my brother of course thanks
for having me yeah atlas
yeah you're welcome my brother you're
super welcome
i know that was that was epic we got to
break down a lot of awesome topics
guys again check out the link in the bio
below
it's kyle's instagram profile check it
out
shadow vision also check out kyle's
other work you can find a lot of it on
his instagram page you can find
a lot of it also it's coming soon we'll
have a new updated website that will
work
the link will be in the bio uh shadow
vision.vision.com
and then we'll have that also in the bio
for when that's ready and we'll have a
lot of the stuff catalog
there of these awesome videos and reels
and all the stuff that we were
showcasing
um so also
you know share more in terms of what you
learned on the art of video
share that more with other people like
we talked about these master classes in
photography or videography that we were
talking about
if you know people that need to watch
this video to get going in those fields
share this with them
let kyle inspire them through what he
knows
through the videos that we shared in the
breakdowns and so they can get started
and growing
so share this with them like those
videos like the video subscribe comment
below with your thoughts
and then also support the other artists
entrepreneurs spiritual leaders
scientists engineers
people in your communities that you
believe and support them and help them
grow support them and help them flourish
you can find simulation our show links
below you can help us support us as well
and that's it that's a wrap folks we
love you very much love it
thank you for tuning in for other people
you know bring people up like that
great i love it be a portal for other
people
i love that that's a perfect way to rap
my brother that's it